WAS COMING
NOW, TO GET ZONE TIME, THEY GET
THE PUCK AROUND, AND I BOARD, A
THAT IS A BLUE LINE.
OF  13th SEASON.
MEIER'S  SWINGSTS IT.
THAT IS EASY PICKING FOR ILYA
SAMSONOV.
>> Craig: YOU'VE GOT TO
WITH TIMO MEIER IN TOWN OF THE
RECENT FIVE GOAL PERFORMANCE
HAS PROMPTED THE LOOK BACK A HIH
GREGOR SCORES.
GREGOR, FROM
>> Craig: I THINK AT ONE TIME,
WE SIGNED N TIGHT RS.
AL KOKEN, RINGSIDE REPORTER .
WE GET SET FOR THE SECONA STRET
SAMSON
THAT IS WHERE THEY HAD PROBLEMS
IN THE FIRST PERIOD, BETWEEN
THE TWO BLUE LINES .  INC.
RICOCHETED OFF THE DEFENDER'S
STICK AND MISSED K K IT OFF AGA
>> Craig: A CHANCE
WASHINGTON,  WITH
BA WAY DOWN.
ICING HERE FOR THE CAPITALS.
>> Craig: SOME OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THE WASHINGTON CAPITALS TO
TRY TO BEAT REIMER, OF THE
SEASON WHERE THEY MAY BE SAYING
HISTORY TO GET FIVE AGAINST THE
SHARKSNUES.
WHAT A PLA JOSE.
FEHERVARY
THEN SCHULTZ.
SCHULTZ  HAS BEEN WATC POST WAS
OFF.
HERE IS A LOOK AT IT, THE PLAY
BY OV.
THERE
MELOCHE, WHO HAD THE LEAD GOAL
BACK IN THE SECOND  PEERS SAN
JOSE DID NOT GET V V.  HE IS
WAITING FOR THE CENTER DRIVE
GUY, AND